c'est un premier pas vers la finale de
la Liga les volleyeurs tours enjaux se
sont imposés dimanche face à Tourcoing 3
7 à 2 une victoire dans la douleur face
à des Nordistes qui n'ont rien lâché le
deuxième match de ces demi-finales et
programmé mercredi et cette fois-ci dans
les hautes France retour sur les temps
forts du match de ce week-end avec les
la Turquie
c'est la libération après cinq sept
endiablées le tour volley-ball s'impose
face à Tourcoing
mais pas sans frayeur pourtant la soirée
commençait plutôt bien les deux premiers
sets sont disputés mais toujours en
faveur du DVB et avec la manière 25 22 à
chaque fois menant de 7 à 0 on aurait pu
croire que la victoire était toute
tracée mais loin de là on commence très
bien à eux ils ont après ils ont très
bien joué bien sûr c'est c'est pas par
hasard qui on joue au 5 7 contre
Tourcoing c'est déjà troisième fois
donc c'est c'est bien gagné bien sûr la
victoire c'est plus important n'importe
quelle manière parce qu'ensuite
Tourcoing hausse le ton et l'avantage
change de camp pour la première fois à
12 contre 13 avec un ice signé Reichert
l’ascendant est renversé score final 21
à 25 alors les tours enjaux sortent les
crocs pour ce quatrième set avec 1 2 et
3 smashes par Palom ski et Dramé la
bataille est lancée et elle sera
éprouvante
[Applaudissements]
au coude à coup de le TGV manque sa
balle de match et Tourcoing en profite
pour rafler le set 25 à 27 le